hi I am Jane Levy you might know me as
Zoe from Zoe's extraordinary playlist I
am here to reveal some insight on our
girl Zoe so let's get to it
this is character fate I play Zoe Clark
a 30-something San Francisco Tech coder
who has a supernatural ability where she
can hear other people's thoughts but
Express through musical numbers typical
because of our wonderful fans of the
show we have made a Christmas TV movie
coming out this holiday season called
Zoe's extraordinary Christmas I don't
want to know anything about my dad and
be apart from my family for the holidays
it's not the place she doesn't feel
right I want us all to be together and
have the most Mitch Christmas ever and
if you remember at the end of season 2
max also has this extraordinary power so
in this movie you're going to see Zoe
and Max reading each other's minds and
singing and dancing at each other
[Music]
again typical
you know if I think of Zoe at age 70 I
would like to believe that she becomes
some sort of yoda-esque person and she
finds other people with superpowers and
she mentors them but honestly I think
that she would just be at the tech
company still like Joan 4.0 and you know
as neurotic as ever but with maybe a
little bit bigger of a heart I wonder if
Zoe will have children she's a little
bit of a mess she's getting better or
she's maturing I should say but if she
did have kids I often wonder about the
lineage of this musical power the super
power but I think the beautiful thing
about our shows there's a great metaphor
about what Zoe goes through which is you
can't control or Force things in life
sometimes you have to just let the music
carry you metaphorically and in this
case literally the point was like maybe
that's what she's going to teach teacher
kids
right like I'm like instead of passing
on the gift she'll pass on the lesson of
her gift I don't know maybe I tried to
get too deep what about Mo I mean in my
fantasy Zoe and mo moved to Paris
because I would really like to shoot in
Europe and continue to make this show
and also I think that just makes sense
because I would like to go to Europe and
do the show in Paris but I think that Mo
and Zoe have a deep bond that will last
for a long time it's funny we once asked
Alex if who Alex Noel who plays Mo if he
would be friends with Zoe in real life
and there was no hesitation he just said
no
[Laughter]
I took it like a little bit as a defense
just a tiny bit in Zoe's old age I mean
I don't know what it would be like to
have this power and if like eventually
you just like get raw and you like have
no feelings anymore and people are like
crying their eyes out I mean I doubt
that that's what Zoe's gonna be doing
but I would like to believe also that
when she finally becomes as empathetic
and conscious and loving as possible
maybe she's like relieved of this thing
because even though it's a gift at many
times I think it would be hard to live
with
I like to imagine
that she didn't know but her dad had
that ability too and that you know from
his perspective when he was in the last
years of his life he was also seeing
Zoe's beautiful heart because it's
always somebody who you know hides which
she's actually feeling because she's
scared and so I love to believe that
they were having these like love songs
back and forth or maybe we find out
later that Maggie in fact had this power
when she was young and that's how she
found her dad because in our story like
when Zoe started to embrace her gifts
she finds true love and Max so maybe the
same thing happened with Maggie and
Mitch thanks for having me Drew this was
truly extraordinary
[Music]